Lột giữ lột giữ đổi đạo lột tổ chức chính phủ sẽ đáng dân chủ đếp về công quyền tuc lời
Được thông qua trong phía nóc tổn thề có phụi,
bôi môi trăm mẹ mì tư vấn thận, một phíau châu quan hăng vưu chắng
Đây là giữ lột cải tổ chính phủ đồ tiên dưới thời tổn thống li trên mây không
Lời dùng chiến của giữ lột là đề xuất bài bỏ cơ quan công tổ
và thành lập hạt cơ quan mới để tích quán quyền điều tra vào chí tổ.
Giữ lột công kêu cỏa tức bỏa cho lập kế hoặc rất xác của bỏ kế tế và tạ chính
Lột thời thích lập một tơ quan quán li ngân xác,
chức thuộc văn phòng thủ tưởng,
ngoài ra quyền giáp sách chính xách năng lượng của bỏ thương mại công nghiệp và năng lượng
sẽ được chuyển rao sàng bỏ môi trường.
Đảng quyền lực cúc dân, PPP đối lập đã phản đối dưới lột.
Cho rằng văn kiện này được thông qua vận kế các nghỉ sĩ chưa có đồ thời gian,
lể thảo lộn tả quốc hội.